yo what's up y'all I said boy Q I want
to welcome you out back to musical dares
the show we do the classic game of
musical chairs
throw some dares in there and make
people eat some nasty let's get into
this game y'all hey what's up my name is
Matt glitzy and I'm going to win hey
y'all my name is Hannah and I'm here to
secure the bag hi my name is Nicole tan
and I'm ready to spit my little butt in
this chair what's up I'm Brian and I'm
ready to win this my name is Anthony and
you better move up out my way cuz I'm
sitting down whoo you know the cast
you know who's playing the rules of
musical dares are simple we have four
chairs three of the chairs of white and
one of the chairs is red the red chair
is the Dare chair if the music stops you
land in the dare chair
or don't get a chair at all you're
either gonna be eating some disgusting
or you'll be heading home for the day
winner gets one hundred and fifty
dollars cash or a special grand prize
let's get into this first for all y'all
[Music]
oh okay let's get the walking oh-ho it
dancing no games
hey okay
it's got a little bit okay okay oh I
like this song
[Music]
all right so Anthony Hanna Ryan you guys
are safe you got the white seriously
step over to the side
all right gonna cold mag unfortunately
Nicole you got the red chair Mac you did
not get a chair that means you guys are
gonna be going over to the dare table
Nicole how you feeling right now kind of
scared definitely should be our first
deer is always pretty light but it's
gonna still be nasty
smells kind of spicy oh yeah it's
definitely gonna be spicy so we got
there just a little donut hello sir rats
are on there Hot Cheetos I wouldn't want
to eat it but it's up to you so you can
eat that move on to the next round or my
boy Mackin hop in here for you I want
that cash I whoa that's taking like it
that's round one you're a trooper Nicole
you are not afraid of a spicy doughnut I
would be but you are not afraid Mack I
appreciate you coming out bro but I
gotta ask you to get up out of here cuz
there's a mighty gotta get this cash bro
it's not I gotta get this cash good luck
everybody
all right yeah that was around one
unfortunately my boy Mac had to go he
had to sweat he had the class in musical
chairs you gotta have the speed baby so
we're gonna go for round two
y'all get back in every on Saturdays
musical let's get it
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
somebody like oh man oh man Anthony
Hanna
you guys got the white tears you guys
are safe congratulations congratulations
Nicole I need you to step back up here
with Brian because you guys got to
figure out what your next dare is I
don't know if you like me but I'm tired
man when I get tired I like a good latte
bro how about you I love coffee Oh
amazing
well let me introduce you to this
anchovy latte bro I want you to dig that
spoon in there take a couple sips man
let me know what you think bro he said
what ancho ancho v-loc whoa whoa
turn around a little bit just so you can
see a minute rate I mean it's in there
well listen Brian I don't want to force
you bro Nicole is here she already
showed us this she does not give up
right so if you want to you can pass
this off to Nicole or if you want to
stick in this game and get that bread
let me know I know Punk I'm gonna do it
alright say no say no more
let's get a couple sets may be either
here show me show me by that light bro
couple sit oh I don't think about
oh my god more take a sit
no mas oh my god Louis said Louis have
you got you got you got it there you go
my boy bright light let's go Bryan
listen it ain't easy man you tell me
like coffee bro listen man Bryan is not
afraid of anchovy latte how would be but
men you killed that bro thank you
so Nicole you showed us that you had
some heart you showed us you bought that
life but unfortunately what we do know
is that in musical dares you gotta have
that speed so I gotta ask you to go cuz
somebody gotta get this Cassady somebody
got get this cash alright yeah that was
wrong - unfortunately Nicola had to go
she was super sweet but for this game
you got to be quick on her feet so let's
get into round three y'all let's get out
here let's see who's going home tonight
let's see go get that cash I like this
one
[Applause]
welcome here alright Brian you've been
here before you know us up Hannah it's
your first time luckily for you this is
only a mystery challenge so you're not
gonna have anything but you guys are
gonna have to go head-to-head in a
staring contest okay in three two one
[Music]
how you feeling bro you did so good I'm
proud I'm proud you probably oh man i'ma
have to ask you to get up out of here
because one DS to go get some cash today
oh man my boy Brian had to go I can't
even lie I really like Brian liked the
way he ate those anchovies but listen we
got to find a route we got two
contestants that are really trying to
get this cash let's get to this dancing
[Laughter]
I'm letting play for a little bit this
is the final round if you want this cast
we're not playing no games with you so
what I want you to do is check out our
final Lots a man and I know you said
you'd like coffee bro so just take this
out let me know if you think I'm not
even ready to go over there
Hannah's right here and she's trying to
get this bad bro what you lookin at
right now we call it a zebra latte
inside we got some wings
bull wings they fly ants flying ends you
let me know where's the coffee
I'm like stressed right now cause like
I'm stressed for you like all right look
my man raise no you know
you know okay okay hey I ate ants so I
feel good I guess the coffee was good
but the ants was crunchy crunchy crunchy
well listen man I got it thank you
brother you killed I got it was just
like trying to go with the music and
always trying to get a little leg in
real quick ah leave it the leg and you
know a little swivel smooth that's what
it was put the leg in and bump yeah a
little swivel half there you go real
quick contestants that's a treatment
yeah thanks bro
[Music]